everyone at school calls me Junior Tiger
Woods sometimes the teachers actually do
I want to be Tiger Woods I don't like
being referred to Tiger Woods I like me
and Chris tiles I don't think that many
African American kids play golf because
the average parent doesn't know about
Gough they know about football
basketball they think that's the only
way out of the hood is to play
basketball and make it to the NBA or the
NFL I grew up in South Central Los
Angeles in the middle of the crack
epidemic football was like your way out
so I wanted him to be a football player
but the minute I saw him swing that Golf
Club I knew that this was for him I hit
that first ball it was easy like there
was some one guy guide you through a
hole swing like we answer one plus one
you know it's two lesson was felt like
he wants out of Lancaster and he knows
that Golf is his way out of Lancaster
it's his ticket to college it's his
ticket to a career do the tour or
whatever the case may be this is
Christopher's gift that God gave him why
not let him shine
on the golf course Christopher's intense
businesslike cutthroat
I'm determined to win I like winning my
whole family's competitive and don't
really like to lose when he won his
first state championship I cry like a
little baby
how for a state championship in 2011
California State Championship 2012 won
the state championship in 2013 in the
zone playing good feels like you're on
top of everything but everyone else in
the term is like an ant you're a giant
being african-american in golf
when you go to above us people the first
thing they're gonna say oh the next
Tiger Woods in the beginning I got
caught up in that he's going to be the
next Tiger Woods we're gonna be rich
vice to have the same for him when he
was seven eight years old make putt to
make money every day they were going to
birdies and just hitting balls I had him
on a range in the snow it was we cleared
a spot in the mat you couldn't see the
ball line it's freezing outside he was
seven and a half and I had him in a
range and he wanted to be out there mind
you but still what parent has his kid
golfing in the snow lay off crazy
my dad has quit his job for me to
practice I'm unemployed and so my wife
takes care all the bills and all the
necessities that we need around the
house her role is the provider my mom
after work that's refreshing she asked
me if I'm gonna practice how was school
first how's practice how'd you do
it's been a huge financial strain as far
as the home for Chris golf we downsize
our house to the house we live in now
which is considerably smaller keep the
lights on food and the table
everything's a struggle for my wife
because there's only one income in all
reality mom can afford college my dad
tells me if you're not feeling pressure
and you're not you're not ready to go
into it for me at least it was ingrained
as a youngster to be aggressive and to
be volatile when it comes to sports in
competition and of course we were like
enemies
I remember one tournament we were
arguing about a call and I started
getting out of my thing I told him to
shut up
and if we picked up the ball go straight
home Christopher and Kenji's
relationship it was touch-and-go we're
on the green at Rancho Vista and he
misses a plant that's amazing but it's
downhill and he runs at 15 feet past and
I got it fear and I lost it on the green
I sit down sit down I empty out my
pockets my said I don't have any money I
said you know why I have any money I
said because I spent it all on you
you
about the time when Chris said he made
an 18-hole well that's the last time
we'll see the Pearson's you got to be
kidding he thinks we're gonna leave him
because he had a bad score ah but I
think he's starting to believe we're not
going to now we met Linda and Dave
through a mutual friend
we went down to their Country Club
Oakmont to play around the golf with her
and I guess she took a liking to Chris
and myself there's a lot of pressure on
his dad to make this happen for his kid
when they don't have some of the
opportunities that other people have to
perform in this arena I first saw up my
paw I thought I was having nice people
there's nice food is nice everything
there the Pearson's help raise money
through their contacts at the Country
Club
we call it the KS booster team it helps
him play in certain events that he maybe
couldn't afford to play in because of
air fares and room and board and entry
fee and so these people helped sponsor
it and we get the money together and pay
for it most importantly I can use a golf
or is getting a college and to lead
tours college scholarships oh my gosh if
I could see Christopher walk across the
stage at a four-year university are we
the best our goal is to see that he gets
into a good school because the family
but let's face it the family can't
afford it I don't know how to explain
the new day I'm sorry
there is a blessing to our family Linda
is a no-nonsense type of person through
conversations with her that I've had
I've changed if I hit a bad shot
he'll instead of telling me what I did
wrong they try to say something positive
so I don't get emotional about the shot
I just hit
she got kin to settle down and Ken's his
father fathers want the best for their
kids and he just got a little bit antsy
about it all anytime we need help on the
walk-in collar or kid you can call her
and it's just not from golf just um
being being there for us I just wanted
him to get a scholarship I just thought
it was cool that my son can golf and
then I went from that to like I say he's
gonna be rich he's gonna be Tiger Woods
if I go you know what happened to that
guy what happened to the guy that was
just happy that his son was golfing now
it's more about you trying to get rich
and so that kind of opened my eyes and I
said you know what you need to take a
step back and just realize what you do
have and don't destroy it makes me feel
pretty good that I have your parents
because I really care
they want me to have a good future I've
been there since day one since that one
day I hit that first shot
you